zidane Gaborik often wonders what she
did to deserve this she worked all her
life as a music teacher the little bit
of money sheena husband managed to set
aside went into a fund managed by the
Archdiocese of merabh or it was called
the bell or Sivan and Slovenian little
broadly that song we decided to invest
everything in Swansea after all it was a
church initiative and we said the church
is honest it will pay attention to how
the money is handled in Smithfield look
so our whole family put their money in
my husband and I and my daughter our
friends too we decided together at all
the archdiocese of Maribor founded Swan
one and Swan to shortly after slovenia
gained independence the church then
began investing in construction
companies publishing houses breweries
and telecommunications firms things were
fine for a while but when the economic
crisis hit slovenia the house of cards
collapsed serve on one and so on two
went broke
we spoke a budget chocolate i boast a
guy movie loose we just waited it out
buddy hedonic that was our savings for
old age aint company then that that's it
both says little [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden the news came that it went under
and we had lost everything nothing no
one knows how much money was involved
some say around eight hundred million
euros it's still legally unclear whether
fund managers or church representatives
were to blame Rome took disciplinary
measures and forced three bishops to
resign slovenian church experts say that
the Vatican was primarily concerned with
making an example of the dismissed
priests simple signal menya I don't
think they were involved to the extent
that they actually deserved what they
got deleted detox nah you know there
have been cases of bankrupt diocese in
Germany but no Cardinals or bishops were
forced to resign made an investor to the
damselfish Kofi of a bankrupt but the
banker did not put the bench companies
that I'd take out stop I think this was
the result of an entry and information
that the Vatican really didn't confirm
impa in farmacia kanisa philip the wall
a yasno pre very own destiny vatican ski
corrado businessman Rolando crasnick
believes that the lane manages of the
investment company have gotten away with
it he invested tens of thousands of
euros in the holding company's nearly
quadro slovakia to bishops you had to
resign were just a drop in the bucket
did it the directors as one were the
ones who made the wrong investment and
they knew it was wrong nothing's
happened to them la patria then you put
on boxing mr. reveal it would let him
know buzz google the bishop of Celia's
now been given a responsibility for
marable as well he doesn't deny the
church played a role in the scam after
all tens of thousands of faithful
investors lost everything you need to be
their business when a test like this
comes like what's happened in the morrow
or diocese then human weakness is to
blame beaucoup de la various levels a
few people simply didn't account
properly and maybe they were a bit too
imaginative he's so fun to 0 le Malibu
edge that has left the church in maribor
owing banks about 37 million euros and
fighting for its survival nearly all its
property including the Archbishop's
residence have been more ridged the bank
right next door has even gone to court
to get their money it's owed at Saturday
mass and Marie balls Cathedral of sand
John the Baptist many are praying that
the diocese will make it through this
little comfort that church leaders have
said the profits from the investment
firms will be used to finance pastoral
work in the congregation the moral
responsibility remains a heavy burden
church leaders continue to insist that
the diocese violated church laws with
its speculative ventures Bishop lipoff
check has just returned from Rome where
the Vatican denied him of 40 million
euro loan sort of the new innately da
they've told us that there is no chance
that we'll get any money boom or we have
to cope with it ourselves with the help
of the bishops countries both equal
veins there's been an offer of age from
the neighboring city of grants in
Austria talks between the Austrian
bishop and the banks may save at least a
few of the church buildings but the loss
of faith is more difficult to restore
the theological fee up the church wanted
to get his business instead of worrying
about morality like a company that's
wrong for the ATM not only read oh yes
but very left now people are losing
faith in the church's benevolence
because everything is all about money I
think that about Allison does get it
well what's what the church should pay
back the people at owes money to yeah
but Tim
sedan khabar jet agrees but she's long
lost confidence that will ever happen
many buns ethical that's not a church
for me it's not God those are just
common fraudsters the a kiss a little
goofy her husband in the meantime has
since passed away now's the Dinka has to
make do with her 500 euro monthly
pension she has no savings but that's
life she says